hey guys Eddie here and I've got a
friend of mine who you may or may not
know this is who's these guys like after
you having here an election theater
reading this amazing that's incredible
100 look at him we had this empty
lecture theater behind us and it wasn't
empty a second ago honestly 500 kids
today here doing what exactly
just a celebration of mathematics night
we went off topic off book and just took
them into the beauty of numbers and
structure and puzzles and using the
grammar and yeah we are just under 500
kids yeah like we're focusing from the
moment you started and we're still
paying attention when I finish they've
done almost four hours by day and not
only that we actually had a bunch of
people who came from real distances I
had one boy he said he woke up at half
past three
yeah the good the kids from coffs harbor
flew in yeah that's not I flew from
ka'aba Sanaa there was a school came up
from manaro down manera sort of like
Canberra why Penrith from here is the
best part of two hours so I thank you to
detach rule organize Ville so it's
pretty exciting I mean one of the
reasons we are here today is as you just
had there and this is your new book the
tower and the thing that I love most
about this book is that it gets at like
maths can be really useful for solving
real-world problems out there it is very
good at that but also it what this book
embodies is you can just play and have a
good time am I going to see what
patterns emerge and I think that
sometimes we forget that we get
mysterious about it myself and I might
from our city universities called Sean
garner he will be a doctor soon we said
let's make up some puzzles for the ball
let's just make up our own sort so we've
invented these things from nothing mo
funda many where in the world except in
the book and the great thing is when you
start the first time you encounter one
of these puzzles there's like 9 hints
mmm bit later in the book there's eight
ends then 7 then 6 if you went to the
end here and tried the zero hint puzzle
oh you're heavy you can't do it you know
oh this is great I was 9 the night this
Devin and you take the training wheels
off and by the time you get to the end
well it shouldn't a lights out so I
think it's great you brought you book
there and I also want to say a personal
thank you to you because you read my
book before it was out and
my teammate appreciated thing I like
about your book is that that there's
maths in there but it's beautiful
storytelling as well and it goes just
beyond crunch this crunch that get an
answer mmm why would you and your also
get an insight into how did people see
what was the thought process that led us
to where we yeah now it's a story like
you see what I'm people don't just wake
up one morning go well there you go we
equals mc-squared there's a journeyer
understand to get there I think your
book captures that beautiful well I
think it's great that you know Australia
has the both of us because Matt it's a
big wide universe out there and that's
why I'm really glad that both of our
books there they sort of have their own
little spot that hopefully people who
get enriched by forget both of the books
exactly exactly money Eddie when I read
Eddie's book and he asked if I'd be good
enough to provide a quote for the front
cover and have you got a few books
myself and totally with my tongue in
cheek the quote Oh provider was if you
only buy two maths books this year make
sure this is one of them and I've got
the impression your publisher Washington
again look just thank you for a writer's
day today it was great to find a lot of
fun I thank you to everyone who came
along as well are you guys engaged you
you really pushed your brains to the
limit I think by the end of it I got the
sense that some of them just their brain
and turn to mush inside their skulls
I saw trying to walk up the city out of
the lake hey we're a bit wobbly look at
a little trouble but thanks for everyone
for working hard and I'm really looking
forward to sharing more stuff from from
birthday books in the future so is this
going on woo driven am I gonna be on woo
tube would you like to be thanks guys
have a good one